NOW IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF EARTH,
IT IS THE FUTURE.
SPACEX BROKE GROUND IN TEXAS
TODAY FOR A COMMERCIAL SPACE
PORT WHICH THEY SAY WILL OFFER
FLIGHT INTO ORBIT BY 2016.
IN HONOR OF SPACEX'S GIANT STEP
FOR MANKIND, TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
IS SEXY SPACE, SEXY SPACE.
EXAMPLES OF SEXY SPACE MIGHT BE
TAP THAT ASTEROID --
OR GAL ON GALAXY ACTION --
OR SPOOGE NICK, BECAUSE WHY NOT.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK RIGHT NOW AND GO.
MARINA.
>> ONCE YOU GO BLACK HOLE YOU
NEVER GO BACK, HO.
>> Chris: NICE. GENIUS. POINTS.
WELL DONE.
JESSE.
>> JIZZ ALDRIN.
>> Chris: YES.
THE MAN IS A NATIONAL HERO!
POINTS.
>> HE WAS A DICK TO ME ONCE. IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Chris: TODD.
>> NIPTUNE.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
JESSE.
>> HOT KARL SAGAN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: TODD.
>> GRAVATITTY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. MARINA.
HOUSTON WE HAVE A PROBLEM IT HAS
BEEN UP TOO LONG.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
TODD.
>> POON TANG.
>> REMEMBER -- TANG?